trois hommes placés en garde à vue à
dijon dans le cadre de l' enquête sur la
mort d'un sdf d'origine bulgare
le corps avait été découvert hier
dissimulé sur un parking
valentin chatelier vous êtes devant
l'hôtel de police de dijon l'un d'eux
aurait avoué avoir porté les coups de
marteau qui ont provoqué le décès oui
arnaud selon nos informations une des
trois personnes placées en garde à vue
aurait reconnu les faits et avoué le
meurtre devant les enquêteurs il
s'agirait d'une personne bulgares âgés
d'une quarantaine ou d'une cinquantaine
d'années en tout cas selon le parquet
l'enquète va aboutir très rapidement
alors rappelons nous ce matin avait lieu
l'autopsié du corps de l'homme retrouvé
dans un chariot de supermarché gisant
dans son propre sang hier avenue de
dallas à dijon et cette autopsie
confirme plusieurs informations d'abord
que l'homme a bien été tué par des coups
de marteau sur le crâne plusieurs à coup
sûr selon les mots du parquet elle
confirme aussi cette autopsie
l'information comme quoi cela se serait
passé en fin de nuit ou en tout début de
matinée pour un différend entre des
personnes sdf et je vous le rappelle le
corps aurait été déplacé à l'aide d'un
caddie de supermarché pour être déposée
juste à côté des poubelles en tout cas
nous sommes un peu plus de 24 heures
après les faits l enquête avance très
vite une information judiciaire pour
meurtre au sahara ouverte dès demain